car guido noé fouillard jasim de picoty
iceberg ndiaye minimum et six data les
styles en détective in the community
depuis le début du mois de mai 2022 le
nombre de cas de variole du singe
augmente au 1er juin plus de 400
personnes auraient été contaminées dans
25 pays du monde où le virus ne
circulait pas auparavant même si l' oms
considère que la variole du singe ne
devrait pas provoquer de pandémie pour
l'instant elle a déjà provoqué plusieurs
épidémies et pour les endiguer les états
commencent à brandir larmes vaccinale
alors va-t-on tous devoir se faire
vacciner réponse dans fat eu
d'abord la variole du singe qu'est ce
que c'est c'est ce qu'on appelle une
zoonose virale soit un virus appelé i
see monkey pox transmis à l'homme par
les animaux lorsqu'ils nous infecte le
virus entre dans une première phase dite
invasive qui déclenche les premiers
symptômes fièvre maux de tête ou encore
douleurs musculaires vient ensuite une
seconde phase caractérisée par des
éruptions cutanées depuis les années 70
les cas de variole du singe sont rares
surtout en dehors de l'afrique de
l'ouest et du bassin du congo où le
virus est endémique mais peu mortelle
entre janvier 2010 8 mg et 2022 huit cas
seulement avaient été confirmés dans des
pays non endémique parmi lesquels israël
singapour le royaume-uni et les
etats-unis tous associés au voyage mais
voilà depuis le 7 mai 25 pays du monde
ont signalé des cas confirmés ou
suspectés de variole du singe cette
propagation de cas non liés à des
voyages en afrique alerte la communauté
scientifique et posent des questions sur
le mode de transmission de la maladie
qui ne passent plus uniquement de
l'animal à l'homme et l'afrique immense
que l'on retrouve pas c'est ce lien
épidémiologique avec les foyers les
foyers africains et ce qui
interroge cette identification atypique
couplée au manque de connaissances
précises sur la transmission actuelle du
virus pousse les états à recourir à la
vaccination il n'existe pas de vaccin
spécifique contre la variole du singe
mais comme la variole la maladie est due
un poxvirus un virus à adn plutôt
agressif mais qui al'avantage de muter
assez lentement contrairement aux virus
à arn comme le sera ce kof de virus du
commis de 19 lorsqu'on parle des virus à
arn
on sait que ces virus pour des raisons
chimiques biochimiques un petit peu
particulière lorsqu'ils vont se
répliquer on faire des erreurs plus on
se répliquer vite et moins ils ont une
dent 6 qui vont pouvoir réparer plus
vont perdre 8 à sion est typiquement pas
suis curieux qui quittent les plus beaux
mais dans ce cadre là c'est le virus du
vih énormément de mutation en permanence
ensuite vous êtes virus de la grippe
ensuite vous allez sarko le virus à arn
en cours de mutation ça bute en
permanence et ses problématiques et
c'est pour ça que ça nous a tous
profondément les pep's adn par contre
eux sont très stables et ils font très
très peu de mutation lorsqu'elle serait
plus donc ils posent beaucoup moi ce
type de problématique de mutation c'est
pour ça qu'on est beaucoup moins inquiet
avec à un virus hayden comme le penseur
un vaccin contre la variole et donc
efficace contre la variole du singe qui
plus est grâce à l'épidémie de variole
survenu au milieu du xxème siècle une
première génération de vaccins a été
développé dans les années 50 et à
contribuer à éradiquer la maladie là les
vaccins de première génération sont des
vagues ce sont le vaccin de gnr qui le
virus de la vaccine qui protège contre
la variole et qui produit sur flanc de
chez nice aujourd'hui on considère donc
que les personnes de plus de 50 ans
vaccinée contre la variole sont aussi
protégés contre la variole du singe une
deuxième génération de vaccins contenant
le même virus de la vaccine a ensuite
été réélu à bord et au début des années
2000 dans le cadre de possibles alerte à
la variole ou au bioterrorisme
le vaccin de deuxième génération c'est
le même
skins et qui est produit en culture
cellulaire donc la différence entre le
vaccin de première et deuxième
génération c'est disons-le à la propreté
du système de production la culture
cellulaire étant beaucoup plus stérile
et beaucoup plus conforme aux critères
de sécurité actuelles les ces deux
vaccins ont pour même caractéristique
d'être des vaccins qu'on appelle
réplicative vivement répliqué tiff donc
ce ils prolifèrent après injection de
façon
modeste mais de façon modérée mais ils
prolifèrent les provoque une petite
infection qui n'est pas du tout là bas
rien à voir et il y a il y avait
quelques événements secondaires
événements indésirables qui est observée
lors des campagnes de vaccination avec
un risque de vacciner généralisée chez
des patients immunodéprimés ou un risque
de d'encéphalopathie de d'atteinte
cérébral ou dabo myocardique chez les
sujets qui étaient qui recevaient leur
première injection à l'âge adulte face à
ces risques d'effets secondaires un
nouveau type de vaccin antivariolique de
troisième génération est sur le marché
depuis juillet 2013 baptisé imf annexes
en europe et giné hausse aux états unis
il contient lui aussi une forme vivante
de la vaccine mais modifiée pour
atténuer sa dangerosité le vaccin de
troisième génération c'est un vaccin qui
est poussé aux cultures cellulaires et
qui n'a pas ce caractère explicatif donc
lorsqu'on injecte il n'y a pas de
possibilités de diffusion invivo d'eau
capable de 26 généralisée
et il n'y a pas de complication à type
de danse évalue betty ou de myocardite
donc là la tolérance et de sécurité sont
franchement bien meilleure efficace à
85% contre la variole du singe ce vaccin
présente aussi l'intérêt de pouvoir être
administré aux personnes immunodéprimées
et c'est lui que la france et les autres
pays touchée recommande d'aujourd'hui
même s'il ne peut être injectés aux
femmes enceintes et aux personnes
mineures faute d'étude sur ces
populations mais si on a moins de 50 ans
va t'on obligatoirement devoir se faire
vacciner la réponse est non et cette
épidémie est assez limité donc il n'est
pas raisonnable de se poser la question
aujourd'hui
30 permet de vacciner l'ensemble de la
population
c'est pas du tout de ce cadre là on est
vraiment dans le cadre de ce que l'on a
fait pour la pour la variole ce qu'on a
fait pour d'autres maladies comme mbola
de faire de ce qu'on appelle de la
vaccination en anneaux la vaccination la
noce est un principe très classique de
santé publique et qui se pratique pour
empêcher la diffusion des infections et
empêcher la le développement de maladies
chez les personnes qui ont été en
contact avec un cadre la caractéristique
des infections a box virus que ce soit
le monkey pox humaine la variole
c'est que la phase d'incubation est
longue elle dure elle peut durer jusqu'à
trois semaines en moyenne elles durent 8
a bien sûr et on sait que on peut
profiter de cette phase d'incubation
pour
injecter une faire une première
injection de vaccin de manière à induire
très rapidement des anticorps et aider
la personne à ne pas faire ma maladie
donc le ce qui est préconisé aujourd'hui
en france et dans tous les pays c'est de
faire ce que l'on appelle de la
vaccination post exposition le schéma
vaccinal est ainsi de 2 doses de 0.5
millilitres administré avec un
intervalle d'au moins 28 jours
les deux injections selon le haut
conseil de la santé publique d'autres
traitements peuvent aussi être utilisés
pour traiter la variole du singe comme
les antiviraux si impressionnante soit
elle avec sa fièvre et c'est pustules la
variole du singe ne nécessite
habituellement pas de traitement
spécifique et même si la maladie est
longue à guérir elle est généralement
bénigne